well the standard model of particle
physics it basically it's a list of
particles and how they interact in some
sense so there's it turns out there are
particles called quarks which experience
the strong nuclear interactions weak
nuclear interactions and
electromagnetism and gravity which is
negligible so we'll ignore it for now as
a force when acting on fundamental
particles and there are particles called
leptons which don't experience a strong
force and we know about up and down type
quarks which sit inside all matter
inside the proton Neutron but it turns
out there are partner heavier particles
heavier particles that have the same
charges as those particles in fact this
what we call three generations of
particles where they have the same chart
instead of charges but they're heavier
in mass and they interact under the
forces I just mentioned electromagnetism
weak was nuclear force strong nuclear
force and gravity and basically that's
the stain of all where fall short is in
explaining masses in fact there's some
aspect of this animal we expect to be
completed very soon and there's another
more subtle aspect so let me explain
those so first of all it's important to
know that if all the symmetries were
that are part of the standard model were
there forever every particle wouldn't
have masked the fundamental particles
wouldn't have masked now we know
fundamental particles have mass so the
question is how does that happen
and it's because there's a small
breaking of these symmetries a small
breaking of the symmetries and it's
associated with a mass scale so there's
some Maskell at which the nature of the
theory changes in some sense and there's
a particle called the Higgs particle
associated with that the Higgs particle
is associated with the mechanism through
which fundamental particles acquire mass
but I know it's a mouthful but that's
what happens and so that one of the
things we want to understand is is there
this Higgs particle we haven't found it
yet I mean the theory seems to only make
sense if something like it Higgs
particle is there but no one has
observed data so one thing is to find a
Higgs particle study its properties but
another thing is to understand
where does this math skill come from why
is this mass scale so small compared to
other scales that exist in the problem
and also why our forces are such
different strength gravity is much much
weaker than the other fundamental forces
when acting on elementary particles and
the question is why is that why is this
force so much weaker so we know that if
we just assume these masses are what
they are if we assume this force is much
weaker the theory works beautifully its
predictions work but right now there's
no explanation for the scales in the
problem and furthermore it seems almost
inconsistent if you just follow the
rules of quantum mechanics and special
relativity you would expect that all the
forces should have comparable strength
the fact that there's this enormous
discrepancy between gravity and other
forces means we have to make a fudge in
the theory what we call a fine-tuning
and so no one believes that's what's
there so we believe there's something
that completes this theory and that this
thing that completes the theory might
well be something as exotic as extra
dimensions of space a hierarchy problem
is this question of why gravity is so
weak compared to the other fundamental
forces that is to say even though
gravity seems strong it's because you're
a big mass of objects that act with
gravity if you had two fundamental
particles say a two electrons separated
by some distance the force of gravity is
something like forty to forty three
orders of magnitude smaller than the
force of electromagnetism it's really
really weak so the question is why is
that and you can turn that question into
a question about math scales you can ask
the question why is the mass of the
Higgs particle that we talked about
earlier so much lighter than the energy
scale at which gravity would be strong
after all although I said gravity is
weak when it acts on elementary
particles we know that the strength of
gravity becomes bigger as we go to
higher and higher masses bigger and
bigger masses so in principle you could
go to a mass scale where gravity was
comparable to the other forces but that
Maskell is 16 orders of magnitude bigger
than the mass of where this the Higgs
particle for example
and the question is why are these masses
as different as we know them today so
first of all I want to say that we
didn't just jump and say let's solve the
problem with extra dimensions a lot of
very smart theorists have been working
on this problem since the standard model
of physics particle physics was
established and around the 1970s and
there are some proposed solutions that
work if there are only three dimensions
of space one of the most popular among
theoretical particle physics called
supersymmetry for example in which the
particle spectrum is doubled and we can
come back to that if you're interested
but a super surgery works fine in some
respects but it actually there's no
really compelling theory once you
include all the things you have to
include about to make the theory work so
it really seemed worth asking is this
the only possibility and since there are
theories like string theory with extra
inches of space it was natural to ask
could there be solutions with extra
dimensions and one of the ways it might
be solved if there was an extra
dimension of space is that space-time
can be very curved or warped is it the
technical term Einstein taught us that
space-time can be curved or warped it
doesn't have to be flat it doesn't have
to be the same everywhere
there could be gravitational forces
which exist through the geometry of
space-time and the consequence of that
warping could be that essentially
gravity is concentrated elsewhere it's
much stronger in other regions of space
than it is where we are in fact what we
found what I collaborate around the Sun
tournament I found is that you could
have gravity really concentrated in one
particular location and exponentially
decreasing in strength as you go away so
it's quite natural to have hard isn't a
snare it's natural for gravity to be
weak it's natural for masses to be
different because space-time itself
determines the masses and those
computers
so brains is perhaps the place where
this gravity is concentrated so the word
brain is first of all its BR ane for
listening public and brains are membrane
like objects and hired in extra
dimensions of space for example so even
when there's extra dimensions it doesn't
mean we travel throughout after all I
just said gravity is weak if we live
apart from where gravity is concentrated
so it could be that there are lower
dimensional surfaces in higher
dimensions so even if there is a fourth
dimension of space it could be that we
and the stuff we're made of and galaxies
only travel in three dimensions say
electromagnetism maybe there's only
experienced in our three dimensions that
is to say charged particles can only
exist on the brain where we live but
there still could be another dimension
where gravity travels so this idea of a
brain is that there's lower dimensional
surfaces in higher dimensional space and
we can actually live